[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée ben aux personnes en situation
de handicap à l'occasion de la la
journée mondiale du handicap qui vous le
savez a lieu dans le monde entier le le
3 décembre euh alors on va parler
justement de la situation des personnes
de la situation des personnes en
situation de handicap ça fait un peu
plonas avec Marie-Hélène Aubert bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la mère de joui en
Josas et vous êtes la vice-présidente du
du conseil
départemental délégué à l'autonomie et à
la coopération décentralisée C notamment
en charge de du hand des personnes
handicapées katchanabé bonjour bonjour
vous êtes adjointe au maire de bontini
de Bretonneux et et vous aussi vous êtes
en charge de l'action sociale et du
handicap et des seniors et des seniors
absolument ce qui sont trois catégories
pas forcément qui se rejoignent pas
forcément mais qui peuvent se rejoindre
aussi hein tout à fait et Stéphane de
biset bonjour bonjour euh alors vous
êtes un athlète dis sport notamment dans
deux sports c'est qui sont le handball
et le et le basket bas ou ou le handball
à Montini le basket
à versaill voilà c'est bien de faire les
deux pourquoi pourquoi les deux
d'ailleurs ça c'est complet le handball
c'est une are façon de de gérer le
ballon qui est plus
petit et le basket c'est aussi par
rapport à mes mains une autre façon de
de quelque part faire un peu d'Ergo en
quelque sorte d'c d'accord j'aime
beaucoup le sport aussi et vous aimezah
oui j'ai fait aussi du rugby fauteuil
oui à haut niveau à haut
niveauvecorge ah c'est bien c'est c'est
c'est compliqué aussi le rugby non le
rugby fauteuil c'est très très physique
très très physique ça a été créé par des
gens qui sont devenus handicapé suite à
leur sport le le football américain ils
sont dit euh pourquoi on va arrêter euh
faire du sport parce qu'on est devenu
tétra en fait et ils ont créé le le
rugby fauteuil et c'est c'est un sport
très très très physique absolument très
physique et avec nous en visio euh
quelqu'un que vous connaissez euh bien
c'est Morgan lerand
bonjour
bonjour bonjour je dis que vous
connaissez bien parce que vous faites
une émission absolument formidable qui
s'appelle dans les yeux de de Morgan euh
et qui passe qui qui diffusé notamment
euh sur entre autres sur tv78 euh alors
Morgan je sais pas s'il faut est-ce
qu'il faut vous présenter ah bah sans
doute euh très rapidement donc oui
j'anime plutôt des contenus inclusifs
toujours tourner vers l'inclusion du
handicap mais pas seulement c'est pour
aussi favoriser la diversité et pour
sensibiliser et même si c'est atypique
donc je suis très très très malvoyante
et je travaille dans
l'audioovisuel ce qui est formidable
hein et et le le titre de de cette
émission dans les yeux de Morgan est
aussi formidable et puis vous faites
aussi un des podcasts euh puce que j'ai
la la la chance de participer à un de
ces podcast euh qui sont qui sont euh
voilà diffusés par
par exactement merci Patrice oui oui
tout à fait il y a aussi le podcast que
je coanime au côté de Alain Guillotin et
le podcast s'appelle des portraits pas
très carrés et bien sûr on peut le
retrouver sur captivant.lve et sur
toutes les plateformes mais c'est
toujours avec des notes d'inclusion on
fait le portrait d'une personne mais
toujours avec des petites touches
d'inclusion et en amenant le rapport au
handicap d'accord alors on va se servir
d'ailleurs de votre émission pour pour
faire plusieurs parties dans dans dans
dans dans celle-ci euh la journée
mondiale du handicap marie-len Aubert
vous avez appris à la le langage des
signes pour cette occasion oui oui j'ai
j'ai j'ai appris quelques signes du
langage des signes juste pour pour dire
voilà pour un message pour dire que le
département s'engager au côté des
personnes en situation de handicap et
j'ai voulu le dire en langage des signes
parce que que c'est vrai que les sours
et les malentendants c'est pas une
population de personnes en situation de
handicap très très importante mais on
les oublie souvent dans l'accueil dans
voilà et c'est important de de pouvoir
souligner que c'est aussi des personnes
dont il faut tenir compte dans notre
société actuelle absolument et Stéphane
bah pour cette journée faites quoi vous
du du du du basket voilà j'ai été
sensibilisé par mon club pour aller au
chaîner faire une petite démonstration
de basket et permettre au aux jeunes qui
seront présents de venir essayer le
fauteuil roulant et ce sport avec nous
ah oui ah ça c'est bien c'est dire que
des personnes valides c'est ça il y aura
beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants à ce que
j'ai
compris qui vont qui vont venir voir un
peu ce que c'est que le le basket
fauteuil on va faire une petite démo
entre nous et ensuite on va leur
proposer de venir en de se joindre à
nous pour faire un petit match assz
sympathique c'est bien moi je sais pas
si c'est bien ou pas bien mais j'ai de
l'admiration évidemment pour les
sportifs j'ai encore plus d'admiration
pour les les gens du dis sport je sais
pas si c'est ah on est d'accord ouais
c'est des performances exceptionnelles
il en a il y en a j'en vois un au rugby
fauteuil en équipe de France qui amputé
des des jambes et des bras vous verriez
ce qu'il fait au rugby c'est c'est un
monstre il est impassable ah oui
définitivement impassable c'est un gars
très physique il bouge comme ça et
comment il fait en fait il met du
sparadra sur ses moignons ouais i il se
déplace comme ça
et il bloque les gens comme ça et mais
quand il vous bloque c'est terminé vous
pouvez pas personne ah non non c'est il
s'appelle Cédric nin il joue à Paris et
il est F c'est vrai c'est vrai que moi
j'ai une admiration sonans borne pour
vous et pour tous les gens qui font qui
après moi j'ai eu la chance aussi de
faire beaucoup de sport par le biais des
centres parce que depuis que j'ai un an
j'étais en centre donc depuis on va dire
depuis l'âge de 10 ans j'ai facilement
été incorporé dans le handisport que ce
soit le le basket le foot l'athlétisme
les jeux de l'avenir parce qu'en ce
temps-là ça s'appelait les jeux de
l'avenir euh j'ai tout de suite été
plongé dans le dans le domaine du sport
oui donc après ça a été facile de de
continuer c'est facile voilà VO VO c'est
tout simple c'est tout simple il y a des
gens pour qui c'est pas facile parce
qu'ils deviennent handicapés suite à un
accident il y je parle toujours du rugby
fauteil il y a tellement d'exemples
làdedans oui y il y a des parcours
évidemment voà il y a il y en a qui
étaient en PUL espoir rugby valide ou
qui ont été plaqués au niveau de la
moelle épinière qui sont retrouvés
tétraplégique et qui Contin sur le coup
ils ont voulu abandonner c'était fini
terminé maintenant ils sont en équipe de
France de rugby fauteuil ouais ils ont
ils ont surmonté ça mais d'une forces
c'est plus eux qu'il faut admirer que
que nous qui avons été baignés dedans en
fait ou je sais pas çail faut faire ce
qu'il faut qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez Morgan
euh bah sur le côté admiration des
athlètes alors de manière générale et
aussi en situation de handicap je suis
un peu forcée de vous
rejoindre quel que soit le moment où où
on s'est retrouvé en situation de
handicap je reste admirative parce que
souvent aussi avec cette dimension
sportive il y a le côté dépasser la
fatigue parfois la douleur et se servir
du sport à la fois pour exercer son
talent pour sensibiliser mais pour
dépasser pass c'est une situation qui
parfois a beaucoup d'impact et donc en
fait c'est hyper complet pour les
athlètes paralympiques pour les athlètes
en disport donc je suis bah scotché
devant justement tant d'implications
donc je vous rejoins sur le côté quand
même admiration et sur l'utilité aussi
du sport et l'utilité du sport alors il
y a il y a évidemment les les les les
champions mais mais vous-même vous
pratiquez du sport
oui oui oui tout à fait fait moi j'en ai
besoin alors au-delà de ma déficience
visuelle je suis diabétique donc le côté
sport et santé euh a beaucoup de sens
pour moi j'ai un fort besoin d'activité
sportive euh et c'est possible
d'ailleurs alors dans mon cas c'est un
petit peu différent il y a besoin d'être
en binôme il y a besoin parfois
d'accompagnement pour décrire les choses
mais voilà on peut pratiquer la course à
pied la randonnée et compris avec une
déficience visuelle et il y a aussi ce
côté bien sûr encore une fois santé mais
aller quelque part goûter d'autres
sensations y compris quand on a plus la
vue c'est important de pouvoir se
défouler et aller tester d'autres choses
Marie-Hélène k évidemment c'est
important l'activité physique pour pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
hein bien sûr bien sûr c'est le sport
c'est la santé ce que disait morian que
ce soit d'ailleurs quand on est en
situation de handicap quand on est
valide quand on est senior encore plus
donc oui le sport c'est essentiel à la
vie bien sûr absolument ou oui stvan
c'est la base c'est la base absolument
alors ben justement on va on va aborder
un peu bah la la situation de la vie
quotidienne des personnes en situation
de handicap c'est c'est la première
partie de cette
[Musique]
émission là où je voulais en venir aussi
c'est que vous êtes très positif alors
j'ai bien compris que le handicap et la
santé ça n'empêchait pas les activités
que vous étiez très unis mais euh pour
des familles qui peut-être auraient des
craintes des doutes et qui sauraient pas
forcément qui ne sauraient pas forcément
comment gérer le handicap est-ce que
vous pourriez tous dire un petit mot
juste un petit voilà un petit message
que vous pourriez adresser aux familles
dans des situations
similaire c'est toujours qui
parle en fait je crois qu'on a jamais
regardé nos enfants comme des handicapés
et persuadé on a toujours été en vérité
on s'est posé une question c'est veut
dire quand vous avz un enfant qui entre
la vie et la mort qu'est-ce qu'on dit
aux autres et euh et en fait on leur a
dit cache tout tout de suite tout du
coup il y a pas eu d'angoisse je pense
puisque de toute façon la vérité n'était
pas cachée et en disant oui c'est
compliqué on n jamais enfin on était
dans le dénir en disant oui c'est
compliqué on sait pas comment on va
faire mais on va trouver une solution et
d'ailleurs vous allez nous aider à à y
trouver donc je pense que c'est croire
croire en la vie croire en en la
ressource je pense que les personnes qui
ont un handicap en fait elles sont 12
fois plus fortes qu'une personne normal
parce que sans cesse elles s'adaptent
elles doivent rien lâcher et le plus
important c'est le regard qu'on a nous
en tant que parents enfin personne
extérieure par rapport à eux je pense
qu'on les regarde avec presque encore
plus de fierté que les autres
enfants ça c'est très intéressant Morgan
c'est un extrait de d'une de vos
émissions euh et et c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il ces deux aspects
c'està dire le regard des personnes
valide sur les personnes handicapées et
puis le la nécessité de s'adapter quand
on est dans situation de handicap à la
vie quotidienne Stéphane par exemple
est-ce que alors on parlera du sport
tout à l'heure mais dans votre vie
quotidienne vous êtes en fauteuil
euh est-ce que c'est compliqué est-ce
que vous trouvez qu'il y a des des
progrès qui ont été fait dans l'espace
public notamment bah maintenant
quasiment tous les locaux sont
accessibles oui ce qui facilite moi je
je vois pas encore de il y a pas si
longtemps que ça je voyais la
par exemple le bâtiment de la sécurité
sociale à hancour quand c'était encore à
côté de de d'un grand magasin je sais
pas si on peut dire les noms
euh dire ce que vous voulez ici VO bon
cétait à côté de Carrefour vous voyez il
y avait la la petite montée pour accéder
à l'ascenseur mais au niveau juste avant
d'accéder à l'ascenseur il y avait
quatre marches donc il y avait la petite
montée pour rentrer dans le bâtiment et
quatre marches après ce qui fait qu'on é
coincé c'est quoi ça et du coup
maintenant tout ça c'est c'est du passé
non parce que je je disais ça parce que
il y avait c'était on parlera de la la
Fondation Anne De Gaulle tout à l'heure
mais quand quand il y a eu la pause de
la première pierre il y avait un des des
intervenants qui m'avait dit il y a je
crois qu'il y a une personne sur 6 qui
est qui est en situation de handicap en
France et et qui disait bah au fond la
société est plutôt faite pour les CQ
autes oui c'est tout à fait tout c'est
quand même vrai quoi c'est même si même
si il y a une prise de conscience même
s'il y a eu des des progrès comme vous
dites notamment dans les des espaces
publics voilà l'accessibilité mais voilà
c'est quand même c'est quand même et on
se rend compte quand on accompagne une
personne en situation de handicap des
difficultés de tout ça même un fauteuil
ça un trottoir c'est difficile de monter
de hein c'est vrai bah maintenant il y a
beaucoup de pour les trottoirs il y a
beaucoup de bateaux il y a ou oui non
mais vous êtes formidable parce que il
est positif il est positif nous on dit
c'est compliqué non problè je suis assez
indépendant moi donc non c'est vrai non
non mais voilà mais mais mais il y a
encore du boulot il y a encore du boulot
ou à Montini on a on a depuis plus de 20
ans donc une politique d'inclusion et de
d'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap et on a la semaine
du handicap depuis c'était la 20e
édition et lors de lors de cette semaine
on fait des actions de sensibilisation
donc aux plus jeunes effectivement pour
pour leur montrer la difficulté qu'ont
les personnes en situation de handicap
pour accéder à des commerces ou autrre
donc on les met en situation en fauteuil
il a des jeux inclusif et c'est très
bien ça parce que on se rend tout à fait
compte dans ces Deah tout n'est pas
alors même
si il y a il y en a qui se débrouillent
très bien comme vous mais que tout n'est
pas
forc il y a des gens pour qui c'est pas
simple mais pour ma part moi je trouve
que ça c'est bien accessible oui qui a
eu des progrès oui qui a eu beaucoup de
progrès oui alors on a on a quelques
chiffres que j'ai euh euh pris sur le
site de de du département c'est le le le
nombre de personnes en situation de
handicap dans dans les je crois que à
peu près 80 voilà
86765 très précis ça a peut-être
augmenté depuis ça augmente tous les ans
oui euh et et il y a notamment la la la
Maison Départementale de l'autonomie
alors qu' qui a une quinzaine d'années
maintenant hein euh la Maison
départementale des personnes en
situation de handicap MDPH qui a été
créée en 2005 et puis au sein du
département on a une organisation
interne qui s'appelle maison de
l'autonomie qui traite à la fois les
seniors et à la fois les personnes en
situation enc c'est ça oui et ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est donc c'est c'est c'est
quoi c'est une sorte de guichet c'est
une vraie alors la MDPH c'est un guichet
la MDA maison de l'autonomie c'est notre
organisation interne au sein du
département et la MDPH c'est
effectivement le guichet unique des
personnes en situation de handicap et
qu'on a voulu ah ou notamment dans le
départ des ivelines rendre plus
accessible et être plus en proximité des
personnes en les délocalisant dans les
différents lieux des du
département j'ai vu aussi pour
l'accessibilité parce que l'information
c'est très important vous ave fait appel
un système qui s'appelle picto ACC c'est
ça oui oui super qui permet de de
recenser l'accessibilité des
établissements d'abord qui appartiennent
au département que ce soit le musée
Maurice deis ou ou autres établissements
et petit à petit on sens tous tous les
établissements pour donner sur le site
internet
l'accessibilité aux personnes en
situation de handicap à leur moteur
visuel malentendant donc petit à petit
ça se fait pas en une fois mais petit à
petit on avance dans ce domaine làà et
il y a une chose aussi que enfin que
vous faites dans dans cette politique et
qui est très importante c'est c'est dire
Stéphane et là il nous nous raconte au
fond sa vie quotidienne c'est aussi bah
d'interroger les gens d'avoir deavoir le
retour
vous faites je suppose aussi beaucoup à
Montin he çaû bien sûr on a une une
commission pour l'accessibilité euh qui
permet de ressenser effectivement les
difficultés qu'ont les les habitants en
situation de handicap et ça nous ça nous
permet aussi de mettre en place par
exemple lorsqu'on nous demande des
places PMR ou
autres voilà de d'adapter d'adapter la
ville la cité donc à à tous pour
permettre à tous d'avoir une une
accessibilité totale Morgan je je
reviens un peu sur sur l'extrait qu'
qu'on a vu de de votre émission euh
parce que c'est vrai que ça poser le
problème de de bah comment on parle euh
de de des situations de handicap comment
on en parle aux autres comment on en
parle ou personne elle-même en situation
de handicap et c'était très intéressant
ce que disait cette cette maman
oui oui tout à fait c'est c'est Marie
Astrid donc qu'on entendait euh et je
trouvais son point de vue intéressant
notamment sur le côté exprimer la
difficulté c'était tout à son honneur
d'en parler et de rappeler bah qu'on a
le droit de dire quand c'est difficile
et notamment dans le cadre de la famille
parce que c'est une chose de parler de
son handicap çaen est sans doute encore
une autre de parler du handicap de de
ses enfants et de ses proches on n'est
encore pas dans la même dynamique et
c'est important effectivement de pouvoir
en parler au sein de la famille ou à
l'extérieur et Marie Astrid le disait
très bien et je trouve que c'était un
propos qui vous pouveaz aussi rassurer
euh voilà on peut avoir des proches dans
sa famille on a le droit d'en parler on
a le droit de sensibiliser et au
contraire plus on est dans le dialogue
mieux c'est c'est vrai que euh ben
elleelle dit on a on a tout dit quoi
voilà on a mis les choses sur la sur la
table euh c'est vrai que parfois euh il
y a peut y avoir peut-être que ça change
aussi parce que le regard aussi euh des
personnes valides changeent heureusement
euh mais parfois aussi il y a eu
peut-être un peu de euh réticence à dire
les choses à dire à dire le handicap au
fond non ça change quand même il y a de
plus en plus d'enfants qui sont à
l'école avec les autres en inclusion
dans l'école donc il y a un regard qui
change sur le handicap bien sûr il
sensibilisation ça fait beaucoup dans
les dans les collèges lycées tout ça ça
aideou tout à fait mais il reste une
réticence effectivement nous à Montini
on a une charte handicap pour l'accueil
et l'accompagnement des enfants qui
intègrent les structures de la ville et
il est vrai que parfois il y a des
parents qui n'osent pas parler du
handicap de le enfant c'est ça parce
qu'ils ont peur d'être stigmatisé mais
pour autant avec la sensibilisation avec
toute cette pédagogie qu'on essaie de
mettre en place depuis de nombreuses
années on essaie de changer le regard
sur le handicap et de faciliter au mieux
voilà le le la vie des enfants dans dans
dans les dans les centres aérés dans les
écoles donc c'est c'est un travail de
longue haleine bien bien évidemment
alors
justement y a quand même une actualité
puis que à Montini le département est
partie prenante làdessus vous vous venez
d'accueillir on a posé la première
pierre de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle et
c'est c'est un projet c'est le village
Agora et c'est un projet absolument
passionnant parce que justement c'est
projet totalement inclusif hein euh il
va y avoir ce ce ce ces constructions si
je dis pas de bêtises il y aura des
personnes en situation de handicap et
des personnes qui sont pas en situation
de handicap qui pourront y habiter alors
euh il me semble que pour habiter dans
ces structures ce sont des personnes en
situation
d'handicap néanmoins la volonté de la
fondation à deg c'est vraiment d'ouvrir
la structure à tous d'être un centre
ressources pour pour permettre d'innover
et de permettre l'inclusion totale de
des
habitants donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
d'infuser dans la société de permettre à
tous de
coconstruire ben une vie ensemble hein
d'avoir une inclusion vraiment
universelle et ça c'est un très très
beau projet dont on est vraiment fier à
Montini bien entendu l'idée que cette
structure puisse être un centre
ressources c'est quelque chose de très
important pour nous puisquil y a un
besoin au niveau de la population
au-delà de montinie he un besoin bien
évidemment d'avoir un endroit où se
poser de réfléchir ensemble et de
pouvoir être accompagné c'est ça aussi
l'accompagnement qui manque parfois au
au niveau de des familles qui qui
accompagn les qui ont des enfants ou des
des adultes en situation de handicap
voilà et puis il y a cette sorte de
révolution comme ça quiè qu'amène ce
projet c'est la participation nécessaire
et et et et sans doute
très qui va faire faire beaucoup de
progrès la participation des personnes
en situation de capap à la vie de la
cité quoi he c'est ça c'est un
changement de paradigme total oui oui de
plus en plus les établissements
s'ouvrent sur la vie heureusement ça
reste pas des pas des universes carcéral
donc heus il va y avoir un centre de
recherche avir voilà tout ça et et les
enseignants seront les personnes qui
elles-mêmes sont en situation de
handicap donc c'est assez innovant on a
hâte on a oui alors il y a eu la
première pierre posée ça ça il devrait
ouvrir quand euh septembre ah septembre
septembre 2024 si tout si tout va bien
tout va bien va bien oui mais ah oui
c'est quand même très rapide oui
j'allais dire c'est rapide bah la
première pierre était en fait la la la
100e pierre on va dire hein c'éit
symbolique he oui euh justement Stéphane
et Morgan la la participation des
personnes en situation de handicap à la
vie de la cité c'est c'est c'est c'est
important quand même on vous on vous
consulte on vous demande des choses on
vous a proposer peut-être de euh des
roules dans les moi là où j'habite je
suis quelqu'un qui est assez ouvert qui
s'amuse beaucoup avec les les jeunes du
coin fait et ça aide à à l'insertion
parceil y a beaucoup de gens qui au
début n'osaient pas venir me parler
c'était un peu
handicapé oh là là et à force de rigoler
avec eux jouer au basket déconner pas
mal parce que j'aime bien ça oui ben
maintenant c'est eux qui viennent me
voir en fait ah oui c'està dire je je
sors et ils arrivent et voilà il y en a
même qui montent sur mes genoux pour
faire des tours il y a il y a un peu de
tout c'est il y en a avec qui je joue au
basket
non j'ai j'ai
permis à certains de de se rapprocher du
du handicap en faitanger voil de changer
un peu le
regard il est marrant finalement
ouiuse on s'amuse bien avec lu Morgan
évidemment vous vous êtes aussi
sollicité jeis pas par par des des
associations des entreprises aussi pour
donner votre votre point de vue là c'est
important aussi ça oui complètement et
deux choses je suis complètement
d'accord avec Stéphane aussi sur le côté
une fois qu'on commence à à discuter à
plaisanter ça fait tomber certaines
barrières c'est ah ok en fait il y a des
sujets de conversation en fait le
handicap c'est pas le premier truc qui
vient donc il y a vraiment une personne
derrière donc l'humour ça ça aide
beaucoup donc à titre personnel c'est
vrai que ça joue et ça ouvre encore une
fois le dialogue et à titre
professionnel en animant l'émission et
donc en sensibilisant euh il y a de plus
en plus d'entreprises et d'associations
qui viennent poser des questions et qui
essayent de favoriser un travail en
commun et ça c'est super de d'être
consulté mais aussi de pouvoir œuvrer
ensemble en fait au-delà de donner un
avis bah pouvoir comparer et que chacun
apporte ses compétences ça c'est
primordial dans l'inclusion marieine
Auber justement le sur sur l'emploi par
exemple des des personnes en situation
de handicap c'est vrai que là aussi il y
a eu il y a eu dans les entreprises il y
a une prise de conscience qui est assez
forte hein aujourd'hui bah il y a une
obligation réglementaire et puis
aujourd'hui on accueille plus volontiers
des personnes en situation handicap
parce que justement le regard a changé
et puis on il y a une une journée qui
était la semaine dernière le du oui ça
c'est ça c'est très très bien il y a ça
a beaucoup de succès et aujourd'hui il a
il y a de plus en plus d'entreprises
d'institution personnes en situation d'
handicap qui qui vivent la vie d'une
autre personne pendant une journée he
une journée qui découvre un métier qui
peuvent être employé à la suite de cette
journée de découverte et donc oui c'est
très riche pour tout le monde et dans ma
mairie nous le faisons régulièrement et
c'est vrai que oui oui c'est vrai que
même dans les services techniques ou
d'autres ou d'autres emplois tout le
monde tout le monde est très content et
demande à le renouveler l'année suivante
vous avez participé
déjà non vous a pas demandé non non me
l'a pas proposé va venir iciannée
prochaine alors
ou émission ah pas de problème ah bah
oui on va faire ça d'accord pas de souci
ah oui ça serait bien ah oui VI ma vie
de Patrice VO et Patrice ma vi sportif
voilà donc rendez-vous hand B je essayer
de faire ce qui sera le plus difficile
pour l'ANT je pense que ça ser pour moi
il faudraenir essayer le SP avec
plaisir PL ou ou ah
oui j'ai dit voilà avec les en diablés
je fais leur pub parce qu'après ils vont
me jeter
donc
vais non mais l'entraînement c'est de
20h à
21h15asque Bertin si un jour ça vous
inére d'essayer PL avec plaisir et moi
je ferai votre émission voilà mais on va
l'année prochaine on va faire ça et puis
y a un tournoi il y a un tournoi tous
les ans aussi
tournoour je suis pas ce Nive là
moi verriz l'équipe vous diriez pas ça
non non ils sont bons alors on va passer
peut-être au deuxème thème parce que
dans le handicap il y a il y a des
handicaps visibles il y a il y a aussi
forte proportion de de handicap
invisible et c'est justement le le
deuxiè thème de l'émission handicap
visible handicap
invisible
et Marine
d'ailleurs si je me souviens bien quand
on a échangé toutes les deux par
téléphone tu disais aussi que ça
renforca le côté invisible précisément
l'autisme
puisque il y a des difficultés B
précisément dans le relationnel mais
comment mettre des mots sur ce qu'on a
quand le relationnel est un souci j'ai
l'impression que ça invisibilise encore
davantage alors est-ce que il y a des
façons d'accompagner les personnes
autistes pour les aider à mieux exprimer
ou ou à savoir dire oui ce qui les
impacte après alors il y a des personnes
qui vont être complètement ouvertes à
discuter en fait et à même prendre
plaisir à parler de de l'autisme et
comment ça les impactent et après il y a
d'autres personnes euh qui alors déjà
qui n'acceptent pas euh le diagnostic et
euh qui vont pas forcément se sentir euh
voilà euh en confiance ou à l'aise ou
elles vont pas ressentir le besoin en
fait de de l'expliquer parce qu'en fait
selon l'âge euh auquel elles ont été
diagnostiquées déjà euh elles ont appris
souvent à compenser ce ce cet handicap
et donc en fait elleinvisibilise encore
plus que ce que c'est en fait en
compensant en se suradaptant et en
s'adaptant à la société euh mais
finalement c'est ça crée en fait une
grosse fatigue aussi euh pour pour ces
personneslà quoi Morgan peut-être vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus
sur cette émission sur ce témoignage euh
qui qui alors qui concerne évidemment le
l'autisme hein
oui là c'était en tout cas marine euh
qui parler donc et coordinatrice au sein
du gemme autisme en heur et Loir mais ça
peut concerner effectivement d'autres
d'autres maladies d'autres
pathologies puisque sur l'émission donc
ni vu ni connu on avait marine d'un côté
et Stéphane alors encore un Stéphane
c'est vrai Stéphane de l'autre qui a une
maladie qui lui déclenche en fait
plusieurs troubles 10 donc dyslexie
dysorthographie et cetera euh donc en
fait il y a une multitude finalement de
maladies qui créent des handicaps
invisibles précisément comme c'est
invisible parfois soit on les ignore s
en tout cas on les méconnaî et il y a
aussi une réelle nécessité bah d'aller
en parler et de faire le puisque quand
le handicap est invisible quelque part
entre guillemets il n'est pas concret
pour les gens c'est difficile de
l'appréhender et pourtant tout le
paradoxe notamment sur ce sujet c'était
de dire d'un côté ok le handicap peut
être invisible euh et de l'autre pour
autant les adaptations elles sont bien
réelles et bien nécessaires quand bien
même on a handicap qui ne se voit pas on
peut avoir besoin par exemple d'aide à
la lecture d'aide à la concentration
d'environnement un peu différents
silencieux par exemple donc voilà en
fait c'est ça tout l'enjeu et tout le
paradoxe handicap invisible qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément et besoin
d'adaptation très concrète c'était ça en
fait le gros enjeu aussi et ce
qu'expliquait marine et Stéphane dans
l'épisode et d'ailleurs il y a il y a
euh une question qui se pose pour les
gens qui sont atteints de d'un handicap
invisible c'est justement de déclarer
parce que parfois euh euh il n'osent pas
le le le dire dans l'entreprise
notamment euh de peur que on dis ça bah
il est en situation de handicap hein
c'est vrai ça oui oui mais c'est leur
liberté de vouloir le F al absement
libre de de dire ou pas dire mais mais
c'est vrai que parfois il y a une
réticence à le dire de peur du regard
des autres ouai oui ouais et et c'est
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai un vrai
problème le le le le handicap non
visible al j'ai j'ai relevé c'est
surtout toujours sur le site qui est
très bien fait de dépement les six types
de handicap reconnus alors il y a le
handicap moteur le handicap sensoriel le
handicap mental l'handicap psychique le
handicap cognitif et le polyhandicap
hein ça c'est les des six euh euh des
six trace de les les six types de de
handicap mais il y a aussi oui c'est
handicap invisible euh c'est la majorité
hein la grande majorité du handicap il y
en a beaucoup et et je trouve que on n'a
pas suffisamment sensibiliser t tous les
agents d'accueil dans les différentes
structures justement à pouvoir
accueillir dans de bonnes conditions ces
personnes qui ont un handicap qui ne se
voit
pas mais bon est-ce que dans dans le
handisport il y a des il y a des il y a
des personnes dont le handicap est
invisible il doit y en avoir oui mais
euh
oui
pour on a le comité du sport adapté ou
voilà on a on a les enfants qui sont en
situation de handicap qui ont des
troubles autistiques pour certains
et donc oui
c'est il pratique des sports là on a eu
un tournoi de boia par exemple pour pour
ce type de de handicap et à Montini
concernant
le l'emploi par exemple on a euh on a le
handicrutement justement lorsque vous
parliez du fait que c'était difficile
aux personnes pour les personnes de de
parler de leur handicap on a mis en
place de façon spécifique un
handicrutement qui permet voilà de
recruter des personnes en situation de
handicap donc on est dans une structure
qui leur permet de parler ouvertement de
leur handicap avec des postes qui sont
vraiment adaptés totalement donc c'est
quelque chose qui est très prisé puisque
ça se passe à la mairie et c'est très
très intimiste et ça fait de nombreuses
années que nous le que nous le faisons
et on a un grand succès voilà et c'est
vrai qu'on est dans un une problématique
qui est assez complexe qui est à la fois
l'inclusion c'est-à-dire que au fond
prête pas il y a pas de différence entre
les personnes en situation deicap et les
autres et puis la nécessité aussi de
reconnaître la différence hein il y a il
y a ce il y a cette balance entre les
deux c'est qui est assez complexe en
fait dans même dans
nos propres esprits je trouve non oui
oui il y a un peu de contradiction
presque mais bah on est tous différents
déjà au départ donc après des
différences plus marquées euh mais il y
a des des différences qui nécessitent un
accompagnement plus ou moins important
donc c'est là où il y a nécessité d'être
voilà plus attentif mais finalement en
fait on est tous différents ouiou vous
êtes d'accord avec ça Morgane oui c'est
vrai qu'on est oui c'est vrai elle a
raison on est tous différents
je je peux qu'être d'accord sur Oui oui
le côté tous différent chacun avec ses
spécificités euh mais je reconnais un
petit peu le travail d'équilibriste
effectivement entre dire bah bien
entendu oui c'est ça enfin on est tous
égau mais tous différents en fait c'est
ça un petit peu le travail et quand on a
un handicap il n'empêche qu'il faut
reconnaître oui le besoin d'adaptation
et d'accompagnement et c'était très bien
dit le besoin aussi d'être attentif euh
c'est vrai pour tous les handicap mais
très concrètement par exemple avec ma
déficience visuelle euh je peux vous
parler je peux participer encore que je
ne vois pas vos visages et les les
échanges ce qui peut parfois
conditionner le relationnel notamment
dans la vie de tous les jours et donc il
y a un besoin d'accompagnement que les
gens par exemple dans mon cas mettent
des mots euh me disent éventuellement
voilà si ça peut être à moi de parler ou
non euh j'ai besoin qu'on m'accompagne
parfois dans des lieux donc voilà il y a
à la fois ok on peut faire les même
chose que des personnes valides mais il
y a un besoin d'accompagnement mais
encore une fois vous l'avez tous très
bien dit bah on est simplement tous
différents je crois que c'est ça le
postulat de base et ben justement
puisque sur cette différence on va
parler un peu de de dei je voudrais
juste oui dire un truc une petite pensée
parce que il y a quand même des des gens
qui ont un handicap invisible et qui
sont abandonnés par leur famille qui
sont laissés à la rue moi j'en connais
euh oui oui j'en connais deux sur morpa
quand on les voit on sait pas qu'il sont
handicapés c'est des jeunes qui erent
comme ça dans la rue et qui sont laissés
par par leur famille et c'est quelle
sorte de handicap je sais pas si c'est
autisme ou je sais pas du tout c'est on
voit le ce jeune parce je dans ou on le
voit il marche dro à gauche alors il y a
il y a des structures d'accueil quand
même mais la famille ne les met pas dans
ces STR peutêtre voilà c'estàdire que
pour eux je sais pas si c'est une honte
d'avoir un un enfant comme ça peut-être
non a ça aussi ou aler faut alerter les
services sociaux du département ouou
après je parler je sais pas comment il
réagirait si je parlais avec lui mais je
le vois souvent voilà je sais pas
comment engager la conversation si mais
c'est vrai raison il il y a des
structures quand même euh mais après il
y a des parents qui font aucune démarche
oui oui c'est bienmche hand on peut
peut-être prendre la place des des
parents dans ce cas-là
enfin pas vous mais il il y a des
structures quoi c'est vrai que on
parlait justement de bah la différence
pas la différence le le le visible pas
le visible alors dans le RIS sport
évidemment dans ce que vous faites c'est
assz visible on va voir quelques
quelques images de de vous si vous êtes
d'accord voilà c'est c'est Stéphane de
biset dans ses œuvres
ah d'accord alors voilà bah il y a le
quotidien vous pouvez commenter hein ou
ben là c'est avec ma compagne Isabelle
on est chez moi mort pas dans mon
appartement
voà on montre la difficulté que j'ai à
aller chercher le courrier prendre la
clé de la boîte aux lettres alors là
c'est le côté
hypocondrique avec une pharmacie totale
là je fais la vaisselle pour montrer ha
que c'est
facile je me débrouille assez assez bien
tout seul là c'est ma compagne Isabelle
qui avec voilà ou elle est là je la
martyrise je la martyrise mais bon c'est
une francontoise elle aime ça aussi donc
ou les francontois sont comme ça Mo j'ai
entends du rire là quelque
part mais oui mais bon je suis quelqu'un
qui qui se débrouille bien
ouais en voilà je vais chercher courrier
je fais les courses je fais le ménage et
le je suppose que le sport vous aide
aussi à vous débrouiller mieux non oui
ça permet quelque part à stagner la
maladie aussi ouais toujours forcer
faire des faire des exercices les matchs
aussi ça permet de s'entretenir et et de
lutter quelque part contre la maladie
aussi là il va y avoir les les Jeux
Olympiques au mois de juillet au mois
d'août et et puis après il y aura les
Jeux paralympiques ça aussi c'est c'est
c'est c'est important
euh pour la pour la vision de de tout le
monde de de ce qu'est le handicap parce
que c'est vrai que il y a de plus en
plus de public qui qui viennent assister
à à ces compétitions
euh les gens s'intéressent au dis sport
inéresse aux performance de nos équipes
je vois il y a eu les championnats du
monde de rugby fauteuil encore à la
Carpentier c'était c'était blindé quand
l'équipe de France jouait donc ça ça
montre bien que bah parce qu'à la fois
les gens s'intéressent à ça il y a eu
des reportages aussi sur sur la chaîne
l'équipe qui montrait des matchs et
avant on voyait pas ça h et c'est c'est
vrai oui mais parce que parce que on
s'est
aperçu au Vélodrome aussi il y a eu
beaucoup de choses avec le le le euh et
et ça a tiré ça tiré un fort public
parce que on s'aperçoit aussi il y a il
y a un côté très spectaculaire du du
handisport quand même ben je vois tout à
l'heure on vous a montré une vidéo du
rugby fauteuil c'est c'est très
spectaculaire et très violent ouais et
puis il y a les résultats qui suivent
donc les gens ils regardent c'est plus
spectaculaire c'est plus impressionnant
comme
performance que pour que sur des valides
enfin c'est tout ten par exemple ils
sont absolument incroyable ouais après
il y a je reviens toujours au rugby
fauteil c'est le sport le plus
spectaculaire que je connaisse en fait
parce qu'on se rentre vraiment dedans il
y a vraiment des des vol planés des
blessures des ça se joue à combien à
quatre contre quat c'est en fait on a
des fauteuils différents un fauteuil de
défense avec une grille devant et une
fauteuille avec pour que nos rapides
puissent aller marquer des points en
fait nous on fait des blocages pour
permettre à nos rapides d'aller marquer
des points d'accord il y a a un peu des
avant et des ailiers quoi ça ou ceux qui
ont des grill doivent faire le ménage
permettent à nos rapides d'aller marquer
entre deux plots d'aller marquer et
marquer c'est pas c'est on passe entre
de PL entre de plot oui c'est dans un
gymnase que ça se passe sur un terrain
de hand et ouais c'est impressionnant
oui c'est très impressionnant et et
pardon mais parce que c'est vous le
dites c'est vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'un d'un joueur qui était impossible à
passer euh mais c'est est-ce que on a
conscience parfois du danger est-ce
qu'on peut avoir peur quand même dans
c'est un sport qui est relativement
violent quand même ah quand on voit par
exemple ce ce joueur là qui a fait un
hit euh on le voit arriver on évite
d'être devant lui quand même ouais c'est
ça hein on se dit si on l'affronte de
face il y a des chances qu'on soit
blessé pendant un petit moment quoi
voilà c'est violent c'est vrai aussi au
au rugby maintenant vous avez des types
de 120 kg qui qui qui courent en 10
secondes le 100 mand il arriv il y a des
monstres quand il vous fonc ah il y a
des monstres quand ils vous foncent
dessus deuxième fois on y retourne pas
en
général on y va doucement et et en en
basket par exemple en ballle il y a il y
a moins de
le bal il y a pas vraiment de choc non
c'est c'est des montées de balles des
tirs c'est tout ou basket bon il y a un
peu plus de choc de choc oui ça oui mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas violent non plus
il y a jamais il a jamais vous avez il
peut y avoir des blessures mais pas
d'acci c'est quand on se rend compte
face à face ça arrive ouais mais le plus
souvent c'est des blocs qu'on fait pour
permettre la la facilité au copains
d'aller marquer quoi les arbitres ils
sont très
présents dans dis sport ah oui oui il y
a des des formations pour chaque type de
de sport le rugby fauteil le basket le
hand il y a des
formations spéciales pour ça mais oui il
y a plus d'arbitres qui demande à être
formé parce que ça ça les intéresseou il
y en a qui étaient qui faisaent du
l'arbitrage chez les valides qui
maintenant se retrouve à faire
d'arbitrage en disport parce que c'est
quelque chose qui les passionne
absolument oui non mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que je je crois que les oui
le grand public découvre découvre l'
sport je pense que le le les CEO vont
vont faire fr fa faire beaucoup pour ça
he vous avez des structures aussi non de
nouvell technologie pardon excuse-moi on
va par N
technologie facilité aussi les performan
je préciser de enfin si je peux ah oui
pour pour le le handifauteuil il faut
préciser quand même que ce sont à la
fois des valides et des personnes en
situation de handicap qui joue dans dans
dans la même équipe donc ça c'est la
mixité est importante aussi et oui c'est
vrai oui j'aurais quand on parle de
l'importance du sport à mon dans une
équipe il peut y avoir des valides des
handic jou en fauteuil voilà en fauteuil
ils sont en basket il y a des valides
qui se mettent aussi en fauteuilc en bal
je vois au tourno de Montin c'est ça il
y a il y avait une équipe qui quasiment
valide ah oui quasiment que des valides
ah bon d'ù l'inclusion inversée c'est
pas ça ça je savais pas ça du tout et on
on parlait de l'Ance unu de la tricerie
ça non bah non parce que pour eux c'est
un handicap peut-être VO et puis on
parlait de l'importance c'est vrai qu'on
se retrouve dans la même situation dans
la même condition qu ça ouais on parlait
de l'importance on parle de l'importance
du sport et à Montini on a on a
l'inclusion par le sport donc dès le
plus jeune âge on a des des sections qui
permettent aux enfants de pratiquer le
tennis le paratennis on a l'association
ciel qui fait de l'escalade aussi on a
une une personne justement qui a une
déficience visuelle et qui grimpe sans
problème donc il y a de nombreux sports
comme ça qui permettent aux enfants dès
le plus jeune âge de pratiquer et
finalement comme vous l'a indiqué
Stéphane tout à l'heure vous avez été
habitué depuis tout petit et finalement
ça devient quelque chose de totalement
naturel et on forme des champions comme
ça des champions de
parpique vous parlez de monis c'est vrai
qu'il fait beaucoup une action très
intéressante sur l'inclusivité euh il y
a il y a il y a un
un récompense enfin je sais que la Ville
de Laval là de ville totalement
inclusive hein je crois que c'est on y
travaille on y travaille on y travaille
vous souhaitez vousz que tout à
fait on va on va essayer de travailler
ça et on a déjà de bonnes bases donc
très certainement qu'on on pourra avoir
ce ce joli label mais qui est une
réalité aussi à Montini voilà depuis a
d'autres villes Marie joui peut-être euh
oui on est en train de nous de courir
après le label Tourisme handicap donc
Tourisme handicap bon il y a beaucoup de
labels qui qui qui
promuentessibilé c'est pas labelle qui
compte mais c'est une démarche qui est
engagé c'est un guide qui nous permet
d'avancer dans justement dans cette
accessibil un challenge
aussi
Morgan est-ce que vous vous vous avez eu
dans dans dans vos émissions des des des
pratiquant de d' dis sport
oui oui oui tout à fait on a eu alors
d'ailleurs pour un autre sujet mais
Stéphane ici présent au plateau euh a
participé à une des émissions avec sa
compagne pour avec les yeux de l'amour
euh mais euh il nous avait déjà dit je
crois un petit mot sur le handisport et
sinon on a eu des sujets euh plus
spécifiques comme pour le meilleur et
pour le sport sur la saison 2 avec une
personne paraescrimeuse et un monsieur
en situation de handicap qui fait un peu
des road trip à vélo euh sur des
milliers de kilomètres par exemple mais
on a eu aussi des sujets avec de la
joélette euh ce qui permet donc d'avoir
une personne en situation de handicap en
tant que pilote on dit un peu comme si
vous voulez comme dans une chaise à
porteur plus ou moins euh et des
personnes valides donc qui portent un
petit peu la joélette mais euh o on part
sur des grandes ascensions en général
euh sur des grandes courses et des
grandes ascensions donc d'ailleurs ça
vaut le détour j'invite tout le monde si
vous ne connaissez pas encore la
Joëlette à regarder ou à en parler
autour de vous c'est assez spectaculaire
aussi mais donc oui oui on a déjà eu des
personnes qui ont pu nous expliquer leur
discipline et sensibiliser et encore
encore une fois d'ailleurs en parlant
vraiment de prouess euh c'est
complètement scotchant
ou c'est scotchant oui vous avez raison
on va on va rester avec vous euh
quelques instants on va vous retrouver
pour la pour la 3e partie de cette
émission qui est donc le l'hicap et les
nouvelles technologie qu'est-ce qu'elles
peuvent apporter euh au aux personnes en
situation de
[Musique]
handicap et sur les évolutions
technologiques Bruno
euh comme tu connais plusieurs euh
comment plusieurs outils technologiques
et que j'imagine que tu as pu constat
constater pardon beaucoup de changements
dans ce domaine bah justement est-ce que
tu pourrais nous dire quelque chose un
peu sur les progrès les évolutions qui a
pu avoir en quelques années on pourrait
dire oui complètement parce que c'est
très large finalement ce qu'on a gagné
je dirais c'est en compacité comm ça il
y a beaucoup de produits on prend par
exemple des tagrandisseurs pour les
malvoyants on avait des appareils qui
pouvaient faire 20 25 kg avec des gros
écrans de télé maintenant on a des
écrans plats on a gagné parce qu'il y a
de l'aluminium où on a effectivement des
imprpression 3D donc on a gagné sur la
légèreté on a gagné sur la qualité
d'image aussi même si c'était quand même
déjà très bon avant on a gagné sur la
rapidité de mise en service des
appareils le côté hyper transportable
parce que maintenant on arrive à faire
des tuteles agrandisseurs qui se
replissent sur euxmême qui font 3 kg
donc là on a gagné sur tout ça après
c'est vrai que l'image la qualité
d'image même si avant on était pas sur
du Full HD pour un malvoyant faut quand
même toujours relativiser c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a quandême toujours une idée de
voyant il faut que l'image elle soit
parfaite sauf qu'un malvoyant ce qui
demande c'est pas que l'image parfaite
c'est qu'il puisse lire une information
qu'il pouvait pas lire avant
euh Morgan justement alors là parlait de
des des malvoyants des progrès vous
avez-vous constaté des des des progrès
dans peut-être justement dans dans les
images et puis et puis il y a
aussi peut-être qu'on peut avoir aussi
des espérances dans les progrès de la
médecine qui sont quand même
considérables d'une certaine
façon alors oui sur la médecine on peut
effectivement maintenant accompagner
soigner ou retarder parfois l'évolution
même de certaines
pathologies il faut reconnaître qu'il y
a plus en plus de solutions et même
alors la médecine en elle-même très
rapidement parfois d'autres alternatives
dans mon cas par exemple ça ne s'opère
pas puisque c'est le nerf optique par
contre il y a certaines alternatives
solutions en terme de confort exemple
les lunettes les fameuses lunettes un
peu basse vision pour filtrer la lumière
et m'empêcher d'avoir des migraines
ophtalmiques donc on a pas mal de
solutions et sur la technologie en
particulier euh il y a plus en plus de
choses qui sortent sur le marché et qui
se démocratisent une des choses euh qui
a été évoquée justement sur l'épisode de
la tech inclusive c'est tout ce qui est
assistance vocale euh donc toutes les
enceintes connectées quel que soit leur
marque euh c'est quelque chose de grand
public on peut y accéder plus facilement
et ça aide au au quotidien autant
quelqu'un de valide que quelqu'un qui
pourrait avoir un handicap dans mon cas
voilà plutôt que d'aller chercher
l'information sur un ordinateur à l'aide
de raccourcis et voilà de beaucoup de
manipulations je demande donc par
exemple des choses comme ça grand public
et qui se démocratise c'est une facilité
pour tout le monde donc il y aurait
beaucoup d'autres exemples mais ça son
estant qui concrètement au quotidien
apporte vraiment du confort et de la
fluidité j'ai appris d'ailleurs qu'il y
avait des des choses dont on se sert le
SMS par exemple a été inventé par des
personnes en situation de handicap hein
oui j'aris pas ça moi non plus on
découvre j'avais appris ça vous me
confirmez qu Morgane et ben je ne savais
pas non plus je le découvre c'est une
info exclusive voilà c'est une
info que je vous donne comme ça au
passage c'est vrai que non mais on peut
penser euh dans l'innovation le
numérique l'intelligence artificielle
euh et justement comment toutes ces
techniques nouvelles vont pouvoir entrer
en vigueur et se mettre au service de
justement de l'autonomie en fait c'est
ça qui qui est important avec ces avec
ces nouvelles technologies maryine ah
oui oui je je pense à un outil qu'on a
mis en place au département qui
s'appelle accéo et qui permet aux
personnes sourdes et malentendantes
justement que quand quelqu'un parle en
face d'elle la la parole s'inscrit sur
une tablette et c'est accessible
visuellement voilà donc c'est ça ça fait
partie des outils numériques innovants
qui permettent de faciliter la vie le
dialogue le contact entre les personnes
sourdes et puis leur interlocuteur mais
il y a aussi toutes ces technologies
justement dans le sport qui permettent
qui avancecent tous les jours les
coureurs qui ont aujourd'hui des lames
euh qui sont d'une beauté magnifique en
plus et qui qui permettent de faire des
performances incroyables on a d'ailleurs
dans le département installé un institut
du sport paraconnect
oui avec le professeur François Jeunet
professeur à l'hôpital PointCarré et qui
met en place qui fait de la recherche
justement sur toutes ces technologies
qui permettent des performances plus
importantes et pour permettre à chacun
de pouvoir faire du sport avec des
outils adoptés ouais c'est vrai que oui
ça ça c'est amélioré aussi hein pour le
sport les les oui ben c'est les lames
pour pour tout ça oui non ils oui les
les fauteuils maintenant qui sont plus
performants c'est non c'est nous est-ce
que est-ce qu'il y a des choses don vous
dites tiens si si on faisait ce progrès
là en médecine ça serait formidable pour
moi benah j'ai vu récemment aux
informations qu'ils avaient réussi à à
faire marcher quelqu'un en lui mettant
une puce au niveau de je crois que c'est
de la moelle épinière ou je sais plus
trop quoi et cette personne réussissait
à marcher pourquoi pas moiou non mais on
peut on peut raisonnablement espérer
quand même que que parce que les c'est
vrai que je disais les de la médecine
sont absolument considérables et et et
ils vont être encore plus considérables
dans les 10 ans ou dans les 15 ans qui
viennent donc pour des personnes qui
sont encore jeunes comme vous euh vous
avez quel âge ou là je suis très très
jeune 56 ans voilà donc voilà mais c'est
très jeune et non non mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut on peut espérer des des des
des AM pour la génération à venir déjà
pour la génération à venir absolument
c'est vrai qu'ils auront des des moyens
à leur disposition qu'on n pas qu'on
avait pas avant qu'on commence à avoir
maintenant et que ils vont bénéficier à
fond ouis plus tard c'est ça qui est
bien comme cette puce qui permet de
remarcher ou même je sais pas Morgan au
niveau de des
nonvoyants puce qu'il peuvent
mettre c'est oui alors après on pe
permettre de distinguer je crois qu'ils
ont réussi à faire ça déjà elle
raison réussi il certaines des
prototypes de lunettes alors dépend de
la pathologie de comment l'il perçoit et
cetera mais il y a des lunettes euh
conné qui peuvent donner une information
ben en temps réel euh avec plus de
contraste plus de détails une analyse de
ce qu'on a devant les yeux donc il y a
déjà des choses comme ça qui existent et
puis après on est encore sur d'autres
alternativ mais par exemple pour les
personnes très très très malvoyantes
comme moi ou non voyante aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a des cannes blanches
connecté avec des boîtiers avec des
possibilités de vibration selon les
obstacles euh donc des cannes qui
perçoivent plus d'obstacles y compris
ceux à hauteur de visage par exemple qui
peuvent transmettre des sons et cetera
donc on avance beaucoup ce qui fait
qu'on gagne encore une fois en autonomie
en confort et en sérénité peut-être au
quotidien
imaginons dans 20 30 ans qu'est-ce que
ce ser oui absolument oui on peut
imaginer quand même un monde ass assez
différent je je vis pour terminer qu'on
dise un mot de de de gens dont on a peut
parlé aussi on a parlé de votre compagne
c'est c'est justement les les les les
accompagnants euh dont on parle
peut-être pas assez c'est c'est un c'est
quelque chose de parfois de he difficile
enfin de ça dépend de la de la personne
du handicap de la personne c'est plus ou
moins lourd mais il y a il y a
aujourd'hui des des des jeunes ou des
moins jeunes qui sont qui n'ont pas de
solution d'accompagnement pas de place
en établissement et qui sont en famille
avec des situations lourdes parfois pour
pour les parents quand il s'agit d'un
jeune et là où les parents sont obligés
d'abandonner leur travail pour pouvoir
s'occuper du jeune c'est c'est c'est
très problématique et ça Huse vraiment
les familles Stéphane alors on vous a vu
avec votre compagne chez vous hein qui
vous aide quand même oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui est-ce que pour elle alors c'est
c'est quoi c'est un alors il y a de on
voit qu'il y a de l'amour entre vous
donc oh ça se voit oh là j'ai tout fait
pour le cachier c'est raté c'est raté
mais ah j'entends rire encore oui
mais mais mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est aussi un un travail quoi
pour elle oui me supporter déjà à la-bas
c'est ouis voilà faut supporter vous
c'est c'est c'est un label label
exceptionnel pour elle non mais bon elle
m pour les les tâches que je peux pas
faire par exemple pour m'habiller pour
monter dans la voiture pour mettre le
fauteuil à l'arrière pour les tâes dont
vraiment j'ai du mal elle est là elle
est omniprésente cuisiner parce queelle
elle s'est cuisiné
contrairement à moi vous l'avez le vous
l'avez le voilà moi je fais la vaisselle
ta vaisselle elle elle sal moi je n'ai
toi donc voilà comme ça c'est êes
complémentaément on s'est bien trouvé il
y a pas de souci Morgan justement
oui c'est c'est il faut quand même
saluer le le le les accompagnants parce
que c'est c'est très important et et
tant qu'on n pas justement tous ces
progrès technologiques dont qu'on peut
espérer qui vont qui vont facilit
l'autonomie l'autodétermination mais euh
voilà le le travail des accompagnants
est essentiel quoi ah oui il est oui oui
il est essentiel et puis il apporte
alors encore une fois tout dépend du du
handicap hein bien entendu euh mais euh
comment la présence d'un aidant peut
apporter autant cette aide physique euh
pour effectuer certaines actions mais ça
peut apporter aussi le réconfort le
soutien le réconfort le sourire donc oui
c'est très important mais rappelons-le
aussi c'est primordial d'ailleurs
d'accompagner et d'aider les aidanss il
y a de plus en plus d'initiative he
d'associations de fédération qui uvre en
ce sens qui proposent des cafés des
aidents des séjours de répis parfois
encore une fois tout dépend de l'aide
qu'on apporte au quotidien mais c'est
important qu'il y ait des alternatives
et oui les aidants on peut les remercier
c'est certain alors vous parliez de
sourire euh juste en bout alors c'est
c'est ça dépasse évidemment le le le le
le travail des aidons mais dans dans
l'équipe qui vous accompagne bah moi
j'ai toujours été frappé parce qu'ils
sont tous d'une humeur formidable ils
sont tous souriants ils sont tous
heureux et ça fait du bien quand on
quand on vous travaille avec vous et ben
alors oui j'ai la chance d'avoir une
équipe qui est super attentive et bah en
fait qui a de de fortes convictions
aussi mais qui a de fortes convictions
qui est toujours dans l'accompagnement
et effectivement toujours dans la
positivité parce que en plaisantant en
proposant une aide très naturelle et
comme le disent certains membres de
l'équipe autour de l'émission bah en
fait on arrive à apprendre les uns des
autres au quotidien et on partage un peu
ben des bouts de nos vies et du coup
voilà on échange on fait avancer
certaines choses si on peut mais oui ça
fait vraiment du bien euh bah de pouvoir
dédramatiser aussi tu d' avoir des gens
sur lesquels compter encore une fois un
travail d'équipe moi je ne jure que par
la rencontre et par la cohésion mais
donc oui oui vous l'avez rappelé c'est
ce qui se passe dans l'émission avec les
jeunes Morgan et avec toute l'équipe
autour ça fait du bien de se défouler
sur eux quand ça va pas voilà ça fait du
bien mais ça fait du bien comme de vous
avoir reçu
Stéphane merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
marie-élèine Aubert et donc voilà je je
conseille d'aller sur le site du
département qui est très bien fait celui
de Montini aussi hein Chab merci merci à
tous les TR merci Morgan et à très vite
j'ai bien envie qu'on reparle de manière
assez récurrente de de la question du
handicap trs bien très bien oui à très
vite alors merci
[Musique]
beaucoups